("It's A Gangster Party 2" plays)
(Music stops and knocks on door 3x)
(Felix opens the door)
Hey! So glad you can make it! Come on in!
("It's A Gangster Party 2" continues) This is my setup tour.
It's finally happening.
As you see right away,
there is this dope ass whiteboard, where I
keep all my most important information. Being a Youtuber, I have to be organized
and make sure I write down what I have
to do.
(Pewds draws a pe**s) Wait, don't film this.
This is where I pray to Odin.
Three times a day.
Please give me more subs, Odin.
It's a trash can.
Oh, It looks like we've got
a gift!
Edgar! What are you doing there?
You ready for more? Let's keep the tour
going.
Michael, how's the Diamond Play Button doing?
Michael: It looks good! What do you think?
You missed a spot.
I want that shit polished and clean.
If you miss a spot, you're out.
Michael is Romanian.
Follow me!... Don't be shy!
Hell yeah, motherfucker.
These panels look
like, a toddler drew them, but they were done by me!
I think it looks pretty cool, it gives
the room a bit more personality instead
of a normal wall.
I don't know? I like it, alright? Fuck
you!
Oh yeah, baby. This is how real men
record and their goddamn feet-
Can do squatting if I want.
How do you think I maintain this great
ass?
It feels like I'm wearing nothing at all!
*echos* Nothing at all! (x4 then laughter)
Got my microphone on a shock mount.
It's not–It's not the best one, but you
don't need a great microphone,
at least if you're not PewDiePie.
As long as you can yell in it, that's all
you need, baby.
It's an XLR, so it goes to this–goes
through this little baby right here.
I honestly don't know how it works.
Got my sweet ass glorious mouse pad!
I managed to find the tiniest keyboard out there.
Oh, wow, ah...now I can truly relax.
Oh, what should I play today?
Got my- my beauty light...
The ring light. All the beauty gurus use it to look good.
I don't need it, cause I'm good but...
A camera, it's a Canon, with a shotgun mic on top of it, so in case I fuck up and I didn't record my shit,
this one is a lifesaver. (x2)
Look at the setup though. That looks fucking dope as fuck on camera!
Tell me right now you wish you had this setup, baby.
Alright!...My headphones...
They're wireless, so, in case I'm making videos, I can move around.
I can do shit, I can kick the walls if I
want to. I don't want to though...
I can move over here, I can move over here.
I can disappear and you wouldn't even
know about it. Now I know what you're
Now I know what you're thinking...
"This all looks very pretty Pewds, but
what about how does it look behind the scenes?"
Oh, boy. I've got a lot to show. Follow me.
Are you ready for this? I don't think
you're ready for this.
(Dramatic choir music plays)
Oh!
OH!!!!
THAT ORGANIZATION! OH!
Oh, Come over here, right.
Come over here. Look at this.
They go OUT.
I got all kinds of shit.
Oh my god, and it's so neat and tidy,
BITCH!
That's right, You thought I was a dirty
hoe...
I am the cleanest motherfucker.
This guy is clean as a motherfucker.
Brad, What are you doing?
Come on, you gotta keep up.
It's time to check what's inside
I know you're curious
like a little kid on Christmas.
"What's inside the package, Papa Pewds?"
"More pine cones this year, Papa Pewds?"
Okay, so this is actually a server cabinet.
I have so many consoles and computer cables, It's fucking everywhere...
Uh...
(Keemstar impersonation) But let's get right,
... into that shit.
I'm going to link all my specs in the description, cause' I know a lot of people care.
and I know a lot of people have no idea what I'm talking about...
But all you need to know is: this is a bomb ASS computer
and it is FAST.
Xbox above, Gamecube...
I got em' all, alright?
I could fit a bunch..
I could fit
as many consoles in there as I like.
And I lock it at night so no one touches ma' shit.
All the cables--nightly--
goes into one PAP.
goes right in there.
And it looks nice as fuck.
Yeah, that's right, that's
right, that's RIGHT.
Now, it was kind of a problem having a standing desk
with the cables being fixed,
but... I think, uh, I did a pretty good job.
Brad: You gotta' clock.... Is that a clock?
Pewds: That is a clock.
That is a huge ASS clock so I can know
the fucking time of how long I've been
recording and shit.
What is the time today?
It... Ummmm, ehhhh, let's see here it's....
15, and, uh....
Hey Brett, have you seen this shit?
The LEDs.
I can change the....
What color you--
What's your favorite color, bitch?
SLAM THAT SHIT ON.
You ever had–have a girl over, you say that line,
oOoOoOo she be drippin'.
WHOOOOA!!
It's Christmas, baby!
I got the cinnamon
candle,
I got the Christmas life,
Father Christmas comes early in Papa Pewd's house.
Michael, keep polishing!
what is--
what did I tell you?
Keep polishing the Diamond Play Button!
If I see one more little
smudge on it...
I'm going to call YouTube, and have you
responsible.
Are you using the bleach?
Now get out 'cause I need to take a nap.
(squats)
(from corner)
You forgot to do the outro....
Alright, I when I
started making videos,
I was literally on this tiny fucking
table.
I couldn't even fit my keyboard on it.
so-
I made it guys!
I fucking made it!
I got my dream setup.
No, honestly, since we got kicked out,
I really wanted to make
the set-up the way I really, really wanted
and, uh,
It was really fun to work on it and, uh,
I'm, I'm just very happy with it.
So, I hope you bros enjoyed watching.
If you did, leave a like, and as always...
Stay awesome, bros.
Are you playing Pokemon Go, too?
I think it's because we saw you do it, haha!
Ya' catch anything good?
There's a Drowsy behind you, dude.
Pewds: We see the same Pokemon!
PJ: Yeah....
*Michael mumbling nonsense*
We found the--all the same Pokemon! This is so cool!
*everyone ignores Michael*
PJ: This is, it's as if it's real or something.
Pewds: It's almost like the Pokemon is there...
Now it just got hit by a car!
Kay, we're gonna go to the seafront to do some fishin'.
maybe I'll find some
PJ: Magikarps?
Pewds: Magic Harps